[Music]
so tell me have you done this a lot met
people on the computer surface
if - fine it's always the same you mean
them special followed by them that Nam I
don't tell myself breasts up this time
it will be different which is why I'm a
star professor Europe it is actually my
heart my name is in fact not Brian it's
Roy
to the future how much she lives is
worth nearly three million pounds the
lot you bloody bet I'm gonna take it off
is that your grandson it's too soon to
be getting so close to him
I've grown very fond of you do you know
who you are
you're the only person on this planet
who makes me feel that I'm not alone
I know things about you who you really
are you don't to do this Roy
the adrenaline rush
[Music]
what if it is seems like you've had
quite a past enough to last several
lifetimes I'm just a blink
you're not church forever you know it's
very peculiar doing things you'd never
imagine secrets between you God the
devil
and the dead you don't know him
[Music]
[Music]